djebbour qui est contre la science et le
vite
la séance est levée passé on se devait
[Musique]
bonjour à la brunel je suis député
communiste de la 16e sur construction
dans le douaisis derrière moi l'hôpital
de douai où je mène avec les citoyens
les syndicats le personnel et les
collectifs de nombreuses initiatives
pour plus de moyens et plus de matériel
comme celle qui aura lieu dans quelques
minutes
l'hôpital public c'est le combat d'alain
bruneel depuis son élection dans la
16ème circonscription du nord à
l'hôpital de douai
le député et de toutes les mobilisations
il est ici un peu comme chez lui le
rassemblement d'aujourd'hui se tient en
pleine négociation sur les moyens
accordés aux hôpitaux
nous ne voulons plus de promesses mais
des actes concrets complément de salaire
non des peptides statut vive l'hôpital
ils vivent
vive la page et et ne pas se contenter
de promesses après la cri du coroner
virus
alain bruneel est sur la même ligne que
les syndicats d un engagement occupé du
chef de l'état et l'engagement du
ministre on attend des résultats
merci aux couleurs prix il a fallu une
crise sanitaire sans précédent pour
obtenir ses engagements du gouvernement
ici à douai le personnel n'est pas près
d'oublier ce qu'il a vécu le pardon ni
oubli devrait lever raison et vous
souhaitez alors cette période dure pour
vous non ouais n'aura pas ce 15 avril
certains confient aux députés leur
souffrance d'autres se prennent en photo
à ses côtés ou plaisante avec lui
pardonnait emmerdes
nous avons marché qu'on n'est pas sorti
du tas pour moi bien alain bruneel lui
tape volontiers sur le gouvernement
son objectif aujourd'hui est surtout de
motiver les troupes
je pense que là ce qui est important de
continuer mobilisation parce que
ensemble on est là pour gagner et ne
sait qu'on va gagner partout 20-20
brunel on retrouve ce jeune homme rémy
son collaborateur sa mission
photographié filmé et enregistré les
moindres faits et gestes du député
car derrière son côté un peu discret
alain bruneel et le roi de la com il
utilise bien ce qu'on peut faire pour se
faire entendre
moi j'ai vu entendu parler de la chaîne
humaine qu'il est fêtée à douai à partir
de la gare pour rassembler un peu les
gens et justement faire parler d'hôpital
public
et voilà ce que ça donne
[Musique]
une chaîne humaine contre le plan
d'économie imposées à l'hôpital de douai
les coups médiatiques
c'est un peu la spécialité d'alain
bruneel par exemple il a passé une nuit
incognito aux urgences de doué à
attendre sur un brancard pour témoigner
du manque de moyens faire passer pour un
patient à haut niveau de service des
urgences j'ai trouvé ça très fort quand
même
de plus l'âme c'est quelque chose de
nouveau voilà qui peut toucher aussi la
jeunesse voilà donc c'est des
innovations je pense ce slam c'est alain
bruneel lui même qui l'a produit la
vidéo a fait plusieurs millions de vues
sur internet
regarde ton cave un sourire regarde ton
vieux père souffrir regarde ce personnel
à bout de souffle qui ne veut qu'un
soupir
il est temps de soutenir rejoint la
lutte pour agir
ils ont trouvé boison on trouvera les
lexiques alain bruneel ne s'est pas
arrêté là à sa permanence lui et son
équipe planchent sur sa dernière
aventure médiatique 12 ou plus on prend
la halle actuelle du cese donc on fait
l'hôpital en fait à l'interné pompiers
et après l'actualité parlementaire
bonsoir bienvenue dans notre actualité
au pub pendant le confinement alain
brunel a lancé son propre jt sur les
réseaux sociaux
il en a déjà fait neuf rendez vous
hebdomadaire qui n'est pas blessé met à
regarder
n'y cherchez pas l'impartialité
journalistique de rigueur alain bruneel
est un député engagé le patron d'amazon
malgré la crise sanitaire continue de
s'enrichir le tribunal de nanterre a
tranché devra payer un million d'euros
par jour
s'il ne respecte pas les règles de
sécurité pour ses employés
[Musique]
avant le confinement on est on vit à 100
à l'heure on est sur le terrain il ya un
bouillonnement rapide d'un coup pouf a
plus rien l'ol est calme et plus de
vagues et on se retrouve tout seul on se
dit qu'est ce qu'on va faire tout seul
voilà et donc moi j'ai vu la misère
personnellement le vif et donc cette
émission elle est venue parce qu' il
fallait qu'on existe aussi mal à lire
comme ça qu'on existe exister grâce à un
jt
un sacré défi pour l'équipe du député
car les collaborateurs ont dû
s'improviser reporter ou interviewer par
france fait des choses auxquelles on
s'attend pas en signant un contrat de
travail
c'est vrai que ça nous amène à
développer des compétences qu'on n'avait
pas forcément à la base car des
interviews c'est pas forcément notre
place donc c'est une expérience en plus
non le député est il dans son rôle en
s'improvisant animateurs et rédacteur en
chef
en tout cas il vit ses fonctions à fond
les yeux rivés sur les audiences et les
derniers en date ne sont pas très bonnes
pour comparer à le 5 juin
on a eu quinze mille personnes à
l'émission de 12 juin on est à sept
mille personnes atteints ouais enfin moi
je respire un peu plus je pensais qu'on
allait faire entre le 15 et 20 mille
personnes atteintes
parce que c'est quelqu'un de connu on
avait quand même fait des bonnes
présentation pense que c'était super
très pop
j'étais un peu déçu bon peut faire mieux
qu'aux transferts l'écran andré cette
semaine
là on devrait la campagne alors andré
donc ça c'est l'invité andré c'est andré
chassaigne le président du groupe
communiste à l'assemblée
il est l'invité vedette du journal de la
semaine dont l'enregistrement commence à
l'instant
[Musique]
andré on va essayer de travailler trop
12 à 15 minutes
les maple chrono en marche le mythe est
prêt
on fait un test sombrer alors c'est bon
pour lui niva fermi est parti andré
bonjour pendant cette période le rôle
démocratique département des
parlementaires aient repris à la
cote merde tu merde est ici quand j'ai
déjà perdu deux fois ça vient des trois
ou quatre fois après aller jeudi andré
bonjour du niveau gens on y va andré
bonjour bonjour alain andré chassaigne r
il ya une grande manifestation de tous
les soignants une grande mobilisation
également quel est ton point de vue
les soignants il s'est pas roulé dans la
farine en quelque sorte
est ce qu'ils veulent c'est pas
seulement des mots des médailles des
grandes phrases y veulent du concret a
remercié andré c'était le mot de la fin
est dans la vie on est bord de la vie on
est dans la réalité et ça c'est le rôle
aussi des députés communistes tête avec
des citoyens
merci andré bien merci je vous laisse
alors là ok ça marche
d'accord bon et ça va vous aurez de quoi
faire là c'est rémy qui va avoir de quoi
faire car il ne s'occupe pas seulement
de filmer il est aussi réalisateur et
monteur de ce jt quelques clics et voilà
le résultat
sa mère de sept dixièmes et émissions
notre invité en mai chez scène le
président du groupe communiste à
l'assemblée nationale ça c'est pour
l'invité de la semaine
mais dans ce gîte et il reste une actu
importantes à traiter à les juifs font
ce bug fin alain bruneel va défendre sa
proposition de loi sur la santé publique
le lendemain dans l'hémicycle non mais
la première la production faut qu'on
travaille dessus
le semis je crois que les prix non
médecins le ministre ce que veulent les
soignants c'est un salaire décent
j'ai envie de rajouter un petit focus
sur on n'a pas besoin de faire de
nouvelles tablettes stuff les tables
rondes ça suffit constat il est connu et
archi connu cette proposition de loi
c'est un peu l'aboutissement de trois
ans de bataille pour l'hôpital un combat
que la crise du coronavirus éclairent
d'un jour nouveau
moi je n'ai pas j'ai eu raison de moi je
je je dis que c'est la réalité qu'à
raison l'hôpital la santé n'appartient à
aucun parti politique aucun c'est un
bien commun des citoyens
et si c'est bien commun des citoyens
temps en temps on prête à dire on met de
côté nos idéaux on met de côté nos
principes l'osi on va travailler pour le
bien commun je vais faire battre les
coeurs pour que les coeurs battre à
l'unisson mais pour l'hôpital
madame la présidente madame la ministre
mesdames et messieurs les députés chers
collègues les soignants sont épuisés à
bout de souffle
ils ne veulent plus se contenter
d'applaudissements ils ne veulent plus
entendre des formules rhétoriques ou
technocratique
ils ne veulent plus se contenter de
promesses ils attendent de nous des
actes c'est ce que je vous propose
aujourd'hui
merci monsieur le rapporteur qui est
pour et qui est contre
il n'est donc pas adoptée
c'est la règle celle du fait majoritaire
la plupart des textes présentés par
l'opposition sont rejetés malgré
s'écoute comme malgré son implication
dans l'hémicycle
rien n'est fait alain bruneel n'arrive
pas à se faire entendre
vous sentez utile comme député j'ose
espérer comme ça j'ose espérer qu'il y
aurait eu au moins l'unanimité autour de
ça pour dire on va se mettre autour de
la table et on va discuter effectivement
d'une programmation c'est pas le cas
le combat continue pour alain brunel qui
prépare déjà le coup d'après quant au
rejet de sa proposition de loi
il figure en bonne place dans son jt
alain brunel a présenté la proposition
de loi pour une programmation pour
l'hôpital public et les ehpad
cette proposition a été refusée par la
majorité
l'info est là mais le commentaire
journalistique est un brin orienté
encore une occasion ratée d'avancer
concrètement pour répondre aux besoins
des soignants dont les demandes sont
pourtant clairement exprimé plusieurs
centaines de citoyens en colère ont
d'ailleurs manifesté auprès des pompiers
et des personnels soignants devant le
centre hospitalier de douai pour
réclamer plus de moyens humains et
matériels
depuis le déconfinement le parlement a
repris son activité normale
mais alain brunel et son équipe ont
décidé de poursuivre l'aventuré de zoom
actu au rythme d'un journal par mois
[Musique]